Jingle Bell Rock we have an amazing cast
and also me and Tim Meadows
Mean Girls Creator Tina Fey confirmed
production on the Paramount plus film
adaptation begins March 6th and here's
what else we know about the cast yes I'm
doing it you are yeah
the sex lives of college girl star Renee
Rapp will take on Rachel McAdams Queen
of Mean Regina George Lindsay Lohan's
role of Katie will be passed to mayor of
East towns and gowie rice so fat BB wood
will bring Lacey chabert's fetch to a
new level as Gretchen while senior years
aventika will carry Amanda seyfrid's
Karen into the future I'm kind of
psychic as for appearances by the
original Fab Four are you making a
little cameo in the film truly honestly
don't know for sure but I I'm very open
to it oh it would be so much fun I'm
sure everyone would be interested
according to a report they were willing
to return but talks stalled over money
however E.T has learned their
involvement is still yet to be seen
meanwhile Amanda just dropped some
gossip of a girl who almost landed her
role click Lively was playing Karen I
flew home and they were like you know
what we think you're you're more correct
for Karen so I was like oh God okay
sure another just revealed casting
switch up
will Sharp's critically acclaimed role
of Ethan in the White Lotus was first
offered to Dahmer's Golden Globe winner
Evan Peters he
Peters ultimately pulled out due to
issues with schedule or timing meanwhile
there's no replacing the show's iconic
Jennifer Coolidge they're trying to
murder me but if there was a drag queen
Alexis Stone would be a strong Contender
after unveiling his Coolidge
transformation at Milan Fashion Week the
faces of men
with
these very effeminate hairstyles the
prosthetic look took five weeks to
create and it even fooled some of the
Fashion Week photons
[Music]